the migrating humpbacks
have only one objective now
the safe house of mozambique
it's a whale-birthing paradise
far from the usual hunting grounds of
great white sharks
[Music]
vulnerable baby whales can nurse grow
and gain strength
the adults have traveled 4 000 miles to
safety
the warm water and lack of predators
give their species
the best chance of survival
[Music]
it's a magical time
[Music]
the whales spend up to four months
mating birthing and
nursing their young
[Music]
this is their time to bond and interact
[Music]
but these adult whales have not eaten
since they left antarctica
months ago
their strength diminishes each day
and the time is coming when all of them
adults and calves
will have to swim the four thousand
miles back to antarctica
to feed
after four months up in mozambique they
start this return migration down
and that's when it's going to get really
interesting because at that stage you're
going to have these weak whales these
whales that haven't fit up enough
that have been starved for the last four
or five months and as they go down
they're going to be the ones that i
think are really vulnerable to
attack by sharks
[Music]
you